jellyfish you might think they're only
in the water turns out they're also in
the air This shape has been seen since
the beginning of UAP or UFOs yeah I
guess people are bored of these little
pills flying around the aliens boom they
burst out from their little capsules now
we get to see their true forms we are
visual effects artists we are analyzing
these videos to see if we can detect any
manipulation any CGI are these real
videos Sam what do those glasses do for
you they help me filter out
well I think it's only right that we
kick this all off with one of the most
popular UAP UFO clips that have come out
over the last month this footage was
reportedly taken at a US joint
operations base in Iraq it is not a
standard or common shape it only is
detected through its thermal emission in
the
infrared huh look at that it's all spiky
and Tenderly and so yeah there's all
sorts of things going on on here but
like what is it let's get the facts
straight before we identify what this is
this does not look like manipulated
video to me like the color values on the
UAP are changing as the background
exposure changes and that all looks
normal yeah do you think the object
itself is moving or is it static uh I
think the object is definitely moving it
actually doesn't seem to be moving all
that fast you're right you you might
notice that compared to other videos we
see like this it's moving a little
slower and that's because the vantage
point in which it's being filmed from is
relatively static so this is the base
that's being filmed here and you can see
it's not actually very big no but what
you see here this is actually a launch
zone for reconnaissance balloons oh
really yes the camera that is on there
is panning across the base so we know
that it's static and we know how big the
base is so you're basically able to
discern the speed of this object
basically basically basically it's like
10 MI an hour that's nothing it's like
wind speed exactly it's wind speed right
now it's just moving like a normal
object being moved by the air in the sky
here's the mystery we still don't know
what this thing is wait really there's
not a photograph of what this floating
object is there are other users who have
pointed out though that this silhouette
that we're talking about actually does
bear a striking resemblance to actual
real world technology that the mil is
testing and if you look at the
silhouette it's
actually it's really
close unfortunately all good things must
come to an end this kind of feels like
it's just a bunch of balloons guys I'm
sorry it's not the aliens not the
jetpacks yeah either it's like a myar
balloon with a bunch of like dangling
streamers and stuff like decorations on
it or it's just literally a bunch of
balloons I got a jellyfish for you guys
I would love to see your jellyfish
what okay is that a dude Jesus Christ
oh okay what did that look like to you
guys obviously is an interdimensional
being what is it I thought this case was
closed I mean it's obviously just a
balloon that pops but I actually dug and
I found the original video clip that's
actually higher quality than this okay
ready for it now immediately what are
those orbs oh oh my God effect this is
VFX that's VX oh my God that's VFX Bros
After Effects motion blur what do you
think was used to make this after
faction now look at
this that's right we're still Pros baby
we still got it dude bro I would called
it is that after effect motion blur in
After Effects if you have something
animated and it moves you can turn on
motion blur and it basically just
elongates a blur for that object but
this is mostly a dark object and when it
blurs away you end up with a dark
blurred streak which isn't optically
correct you don't see dark motion blur
you see light motion blur it'd be closer
to the first version of this where it
just disappears this video is very
clearly debunked and yet in spite of
that this is still shared all the time
amongst
ufologists you ethologist ethologist
ethologist when I was analyzing this
there's moments where I laughed not out
of humor out of
surprise it's this is like a a road
snail he lights up and he stops and he
looks at it and you're like oh man wow
is that a
drone then it's free wait what wait
what this one's a good one I was
watching like this is the people chasing
it yeah wouldn't be cool if we had cell
phone footage and chasing it oh my God
there's a on the ground angle with an
actual camera that's a this is
interesting having people actually
confront the object and like witness it
for T so is this fake is this
real uh I didn't see any of the obvious
tells of Dr footage unlike Anthony Choy
I mean at first I thought maybe it was
like a phantom 4 drone kind of resembles
that but this one's Too Tall I just have
no explanation for it I have no idea
what I'm looking at unexplained footage
are you guys stumped wait do you know
the answer Nico cuz you I also felt this
thrill for a moment I was looking at
this I like I can't explain it you know
I'm just chasing that high of the
Project Loon video
still Project Loon but you know what
brought into the computer I did some
enhances computer freeze frame computer
rotate footage computer Zoom computer
enhance
I thought you were messing with me at
first that is like a slap in the face
turns out Bugs Bunny upside down kind of
looks like a jellyfish yep and they're
they have the light on on their phone
when they're filming it so it's just
reflecting the blue LED light from the
phone which is what's giving the
impression of having like eyeballs and
stuff that is so good I got one I want
to show you guys at first I was like
there's no way this is a jellyfish again
till I did some analysis the B looks
correct the autofocus looks correct just
a light at the moment I figured it out
all I did was just take the footage
zoomed in a little bit enhanced it so
what we're actually seeing here
guys is an award-winning
template oh my God from Squarespace well
done Ren that was amazing yeah that's
right this video is sponsored by
Squarespace they make it really easy to
make a website cuz all you got to do is
just choose from one of their templates
and then drag it can drop a bunch of new
features on it and next thing you know
you've got a custom website that you
made yourself and it didn't even take
you that long or that much effort but if
it was just a website it wouldn't be
that useful cuz these days people sell
stuff on websites and they make that
incredibly Easy by building out an
entire store for you whether it's
selling physical items or digital Goods
or even offering Services you can do all
of that through a store built on your
website through these features oh and
what's really cool is that they actually
unify this for those people who want to
sell stuff in person it'll track all
your orders and inventory and actually
sync up the customer data through your
website you can even sell memberships
for certain parts of your website let's
say you have a really really cool forum
and you want to have a bunch of people
hanging out there well you can monetize
that through the membership that
Squarespace provides these are just like
some of the features that Squarespace
provides so all you got to do you know
the drill just click that link in the
description or go to squarespace.com
cordor crew and guess what you'll get
10% off your first website or domain
it's that easy Squarespace makes it
happen but that's enough from my tongue
to your
mouth
let's get back to
debunking wait did you guys hear about
the the Miami Mall creature Floridians
they're like just regular Floridians
turns out there's a bunch of unexplained
things that happened all at the same
time at a mall in Miami starting with a
riot on New Year's Day there was a
massive police response in downtown
Miami Rowdy crowds police trying to
disperse them to show you that massive
police presence that was here they
literally sent all of the
police it's like crazy like we just see
all these people running
like but then people are talking about
they shut down all of the airspace over
the city they shut down the police
scanners and people were hearing
gunshots developing overnight new video
of the chaos right outside Bayside
Marketplace moments after shots were
fired man like we trying to we trying to
follow the follow the crowd get out of
there I look back I look back no cap yo
No Cap I look back it looked like like
like a big ass Shadow but it was solid
at the same time like a few like a few
shadows and then there is footage of a
creature that was probably like 10 ft
tall just walking
across see it yet I mean I see something
kind of moving but it's kind of it's
kind of see something floating is that
white shape right there that yeah you
see the creature walking I don't know
what it is honestly this is the clip
that went viral this is what everyone
was like oh my God aliens are real but
of course everything has been debunked
the airspace was not at all shut down
the police scanners were not turned off
the gunshots were actually just
fireworks most likely this guy who gave
a an accounting of it admitted being
like guys I made it up I was trolling
you guys are stupid but that still
doesn't explain what is that creature
moving across the scene well I did some
analysis I found a slightly higher
quality video with less compression and
then I stabilized it around the creature
and I ran it through some upscaling and
so it is three people walking side by
side that's it that's it it's just three
people just walking but you're right
it's three people walking three dudes
Case Closed man we sure like to invent
things from blurry pixels don't we it
was a situation that ballooned out of
control the reason why all the police
were sent is because they thought it was
a terrorist attack M and this just kept
making the rounds for the last two
straight weeks people keep grasping for
alien straws that they can't suck out of
you're right I I do have another clip
that might stump you guys a jellyfish
clip no we're done with jellyfish now
I'm going to present you guys footage
you tell me if it's visual effects or
it's real and you tell me what it
is what is
[Music]
that whoa wait is this a drone show but
it's raining that's definitely captured
in camera yeah it doesn't look like
visual effects at all cuz this would be
incredibly hard to do with visual
effects having the flares disappear
behind the trees the atmosphere with the
rain this would be the hardest
compositing job of your life this
legitimately would be the hardest what
we have here is a lack of evidence lack
of evidence doesn't mean eat aliens I
want to push you guys a little bit here
you guys don't seem to have any
solutions for me is this shot bunked
it's a sweet aerial display from the
Royal Air Force Force that's what it is
Sam's really close actually wait for
real if the Royal Air Force has
skydivers those are all skydivers with
flares attached to the ankles jumping
down over a stadium during a soccer
game that obious that's so obvious dud
now how's this like a UFO right are
those flares of just really bright LEDs
these are people led
suits yeah dude look how sick no way
that was so cool oh my God
well I'm just saying this is first off
mind-blowing I knew people did this but
like this is the ultimate trump card for
for UFO shots like this of anything
we've talked about and looked at it is
so hard to conceive of an explanation
for what you're seeing yeah pretty crazy
stuff so there is still wonder in the
world wow it just might not be an alien
yet hey if any of you have like
unexplained Clips send them over to
debunk at cord digital.com so we can
take a look at them we can look at them
and figure out their visual effects or
if they're not I forgot a physical
explanation or maybe you'll be the first
one to have footage of an actual alien
or ghost or Bigfoot you know whatever
whichever one happens to come across
their trail cam first or security camera
or Nokia phone so yeah anyways
bye